ces jeunes footballeuses de l'usb y ont
cours viennent de remporter la coupe des
yvelines dans la catégorie u16 depuis
quelques années maintenant le district
du département organise une journée
dédiée au football féminin
quand on faisait les finales gars ont
même planté finale filles belles et le
public aller vers les finales garçons et
filles avait personne devant les finales
fils un jour on a décidé que les finales
filles se passerait en tant que tel
justement pour en faire la promotion
et à quelques jours du lancement du
mondial féminin de football
les îles ou moyse ont démontré qu'elle
n'avait plus rien à prouver sur le
terrain parce que parce que il n'ya pas
que les garçons qui peuvent gagner
il ya aussi les filles et on est aussi
complète que les garçons en plus de
trois finales départementales des
animations étaient proposées toute la
journée au public il ya cinq ans au
département des yvelines comptait neuf
cent soixante douze joueuses
aujourd'hui elles sont 2180 à manier le
ballon rond je pense que les parents ont
pu commencer à découvrir le foot féminin
et et mieux comment dire le comprendre
parce qu'effectivement les filles au
foot et ben c'est pas toujours évident
pour les parents là je pense que ça
commence à se démocratiser donc c'est
plutôt c'est plutôt bien
c'est dans la bonne ambiance en plus y'a
pas football masculin surtout à ce
niveau là c'est c'est beaucoup plus
violent froidure autre chose et pour
clôturer cette journée l'équipe féminine
senior de trappes l'emporter sans but
they 2 face à carrières-sur-seine